I think it's the 30th anniversary of
dookie am I right that's right 30th
anniversary and you guys are going on
tour with Smashing Pumpkins right yeah
yeah I think that's a great Bill oh my
God rancid the Linda lindas um so yeah
it's a stacked bill it's going to be
really fun we have something to tell you
about that tour actually Howard yes tell
me we Spill the
Beans the way I think it's the first
time it's been said yeah so good an
exclusive final here we go so we have uh
it's the 20 year anniversary of American
Idiot also so those records came out 10
years apart and so they these milestones
in our career so uh we're going to be
playing dookie and its entirety and
American Idiot in its entirety on tour
whoa you're going to do the full dookie
and the full American Idiot that's a
great show the US tour dates begin at
the end of July and the European tour
dates start in May you guys with the
Smashing Pumpkins that's [__]
awesome